hey stop or not i don't know why i hit
you
you got to make sure you're touching
good dingley that's what i yo brian yeah
this man's not playing about them damn
mountain lions
i wanted to hike with him this morning
i saw footprints
yeah
dude i'm telling you let me ask you a
question um brian do you know that it's
a mountain lion or could it be a big dog
and that's not a dog
you don't think i know what a dog
football looks like no i don't compared
to a mountain lion
dogs are pretty easy with the pat i'm
telling you okay now now
this isn't mud the thing besides my hand
i appreciate both of you i was there i
appreciate it i want to ask you a
question oh you got a couple questions
what is the difference between a
mountain lion's paw print and a dog's
paw print
it's pretty easy to tell once you see it
i'd like a description if you don't mind
it's the padding
and what is this
and what's the difference
and what's the difference in the padding
and the claws
how many pads on them yeah they they
have a difference that bring that up
chin
yeah
tell me you can tell the difference
i deal with all the time so with steve
ranella though i would i would send him
pictures i thought it was a mountain
lion yes you might have known it yeah
really yeah it bums me out i want it to
be a mountain lion and there are
mountain lions up there so don't kid
yourself i'll show you what i sent to
rogan yesterday i told john he said he
said they wouldn't go after us did you
see this
on ring they found a 220 mountain light
yep there it is right there that's a how
much
is that true wrong it was on ring
you see that see the clock
wait you can't do mountain light well no
there's a
cougar a large dog
you see the padding that that do you see
the
heel with three rounded lobes
it's hard right it's hard it could have
been a big coyote it didn't seem like it
could be a big dog we also saw snakey
though all snakey hey brian that's right
brian ryan you know what though brian
probably probably dog dog i know and
that's a bummer and i hate it and i hate
it i i hate it but you know what i when
i look at it when i look at it brian
probably i know and it
hey i've been there let's get the [ __ ]
out of here i know dude
i spent more time on that trail we're on
then out in the pandemic i mean every
would you ride your bike every day you
know every day yeah you know
mountain lions i've seen how many zero
they're so elusive now did i lie to
brian and rogan one time i did what dude
i saw mountain rattlesnake
i've seen rattlesnakes mad lions bobcats
did see about coyotes
no you went like this you go swear to
god come on and you went your eyes were
out yeah now i went yeah
yeah man i saw i go did you why'd you
stutter there and they were here wait
are they up there though yeah they're
all over there but so what they just
kind of keep to themselves and
yeah
you don't see them man they're they're
[ __ ] elusive creatures i saw a bobcat
the bobcat had huge paws man oh yeah
bobcats got huge and then then i ran
into a pack of coyotes when because
remember during the pandemic
those trails were closed off so oh yeah
because they took them down yeah just
wild ass they weren't scared ain't
nobody coming
in the [ __ ] sticks and i [ __ ]
cruise across i see a pack of coyotes
i'm like oh this is not good oh no i had
to they just watched me go by i'm like
should we
and i had a i had a coyote at pacquiao's
closing on my dog when i was with my dog
in calabasas and that dog coyote came
right i have it on video
camera to my dog what's wagon yeah they
want to eat them yeah they'll eat them
oh yeah you were talking about how like
you would never put your dog off a leash
on that like those people that walked up
to us dude as many rattlesnakes as i see
no dude wait till july because you see
all the holes everywhere were they kind
of you saw the one little snake yeah it
was even a rattler i know dude in the
summer when i'm on my trails nothing
better you see [ __ ]
[ __ ] five rattlesnakes yeah they're
april i was attacked by a bee this
morning this just scared me he's a [ __ ]
yep when i was uh with those coyotes i
got down on my knee and they surrounded
me and they
they
kind of bowed to me that never happened
to me they kind of bowed to me and then
they went like this oh
together
and then what did you do well i went and
i and i was doing my i was i was
practicing my kung fu and then i was
doing some meditation and they stayed
there and then i released them i went
i go and they and they ran you know how
much i wish that was real me too me too
i'll tell you what though the coyote did
come in our backyard middle of the dude
some balls on on not outline a coyote
yeah because my uh our caretaker was out
with boston who's two those coyotes are
[ __ ] up a little kid i don't like yeah
no i told him like you can't go outside
anymore right yeah that's right figured
it out
what are you talking about i don't like
that with a two-year-old around no and
by the way mountain lions are no no joke
around the six-year-old seven-year-old
oh dude they're real [ __ ] colorado a
six-year-old girl was
a nightmare hiking with her parents
mountain lion just jumped into the
middle of the grab that child you know
how it goes disappear that's right
and then the mountains disappeared
nightmare [ __ ] nightmare [ __ ]
nightmare
al's [ __ ] up a
little
no owls yeah no is it take your shot hit
the showers they'll take your cat
they'll take your cat now
yeah i'll take the shot get that big
dick out in the shade
oh there you go yeah
there you go there's a lot of girls are
you mad at the vans no i was looking at
right now i'm [ __ ] the summer vans
they're my boys
they're my boy danny ricardo the f1
formula racer and what size of the race
for um uh mclaren now mclaren he sends
me all his merch what size are they
these are 13. speckled they look like my
size bro these are summer summer's out
daddy scout hey we jumped in uh
chappelle's jeep this morning because
they're going to hike is chappelle
marking maybe jump in i go do it it's
like american pie we're going on summer
break oh yeah i'm 40.
my kids are just like my dad it feels
good the summer the sun oh and my jeep
bro i felt like clueless
no i felt like zoolander were in the oh
yeah
i [ __ ] love that movie dude the top
down the bronco there's nothing like it
that i can put the top down today get
the ticket you drive that car more than
any other car probably right the broncos
i drove friday the most you do i mean
the broncos only if i have the kids
you're not afraid you're not afraid that
the ferrari will get dinged no
no no you just keep saying he's got to
drive it i mean it's a car well a lot of
guys don't drive it because what happens
is if you ding that [ __ ] thing it loses
it's
when i worked valet
they would just pay us extra to leave it
alone yeah well i don't validate it yeah
they would just be like hey no [ __ ] no
they'd be like hey i'm gonna leave it
right here but i'm gonna pay you more to
not touch it never i never value you
you're gonna trust some eight-year-old
kid with your car the kid don't give a
[ __ ] yeah and they're they're insured
too though so it's like oh and
[ __ ] love driving them yeah
people that work valet
that's like their favorite thing i never
valet yeah never ever can't never never
or i'll just go hey i'll pay you and
i'll park it where's the yeah yeah i
keep you don't keep the keys i keep the
keys i'll pay for the whatever the fee
is but you're not driving my car that's
insane yeah yeah oh dude have you seen
that uh i meant to bring up on monday
have you seen that documentary uh bad
vegan
yes i have i need to watch yes
i like if you have
my buddies joey my buddy you always
spoiled it all for me please so my boy
it's not really about like being a vegan
so she was like it's like a scam right
now let me get let me give you guys so
she was the like
prime she owned the biggest vegan
restaurant in new york it was like okay
the most hyped restaurant she was right
i was like
woody harrelson tom brady oh so it was
like she was the she
had books on vegan okay all this [ __ ]
making money she's crushing it yeah
question meets this dude comes into her
life this is this the dude yeah dude
this guy looks like the hamburglar this
[ __ ] dude this condom dude he's a
fake so he said he was a navy seal then
then so he gets a relationship with her
and
dude how stupid are [ __ ] how
stupid are girls
in is it like a tinder this would never
happen dude this would never happen to a
gay guy or a regular dude dude here's
this dude finagles her yeah into
giving her like 1.5 million dollars
instead of paying her employees she sent
him the money she let him run her
restaurant
he was getting just some random guys
but he but she thought she was like in a
culture she was brainwashed
but so he was like you know it's a
secret society we gotta do this you're
gonna do whatever i tell you to do and
she's doing all and she's a smart girl
she was listening to him
wait she said she can make he could make
her dog immortal
here's my thing smart no no here's what
i want to get your take on this
she she takes off for 10 months she just
leaves everybody in high and drive
attendance with this guy he's running
the restaurant leaves let's lose the
employees that are working like he
leaves everything and then he's scared
they're not getting paid and they're
like where the [ __ ] is our money he was
still scams mom out of 400 grand okay
her mom yeah now let me ask you this
she had to have been in and out in some
ways that's why she had a bit way way
way this one my takeaway from the
episode
from the the doc yeah i think so she had
that two million dollar nut the loan on
the restaurant yes and she owed that the
guy who was partnering with her yeah she
had a two million dollar nut i think
originally she was gonna hustle that guy
because when they got married he
promised to pay off her debt so i
thought she was like all right pay off
this debt i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out yes
but then she got in too deep yeah and
they got and i think she's a bad person
too and then it just got out of control
and then
that's what i thought she leaned into
the you think she leaves because
nobody's that dumb no i agree and she's
a smart lady nobody said she thought she
was going to out hustle him and then it
got into i think i think she's i think
she's a bad person
she's very attractive what out of the
end like would oh oh sh they go to
prison
yeah but you know what he goes to prison
for a year and then guess what she
doesn't only goes for a year
consciousness three con men get away
con men because they put it all on the
other person
well yeah because right because they're
like you're dumbass own the business
you're the one that was taking out these
loans and give it to him like it's on
you
it's like it's kind of the government on
this like hold on hold on let me get
this straight this
fat dude who said he had to put on
weight to
he's called it a meat
my meat suit to get to a higher level
because they because they because they
the people the illuminati essentially
they they're testing her they wanted to
see how far she was willing to go they
he told her this so he was like so out
of shape like 300 pounds she was like
yeah i didn't expect that he like sent
me old pictures and shows up he's like
300 pounds he's like it's my meat suit
it's depressing but i have to do this so
he's just fat eating uh
he was lame as lies
the worst in the world and and see
that's why she's too smart of a girl
business and multi-millionaire great i
think she was trying to out-hustle him
got in too deep and then that it ends
with them calling okay and she's
recording the call and they're like
flirting with each other because i i
know i still love you and she's like
laughing and i was like oh this [ __ ] was
in on the whole thing i don't know she's
a bad person i agree i was like this guy
is the worst person on the planet and so
is she scammed and so is she she already
had a successful business so what like
because she she thought she was an out
hustle but then also dude think about
all the people she [ __ ] over her
business partner who donated whatever
like a million bucks those other people
she vouched for yup so my boy
so my boy joey
did ever give you joey's hot sauce bring
up joey's hot sauce on this he's [ __ ]
joey was he was the bart he was a
manager at scopa remember joey he played
the drums
um if you you'll see a picture of him in
the in the trailer there he is right
there joey's hot sauce bring him up
remember this guy from scopa his hot
sauce is [ __ ] awesome remember joey
oh yeah he was a great guy so joey
worked there for seven years with her
he's all over the vegan joint yeah oh
he's all over he's all over right that's
joey
and and his hot sauce shout out to
joey's hot sauce it's [ __ ] awesome
but um but but listen he's and he's a
great [ __ ] dude i gotta call him i
haven't called him you can't ride or die
with him yeah i gotta call him i tried
defending him because he's a ride or die
guy he's a great guy you would love it
he's a great friend you're watching like
what in the [ __ ] i know like she's
getting out all these crazy loans you
gotta call joey you know you watch that
and you watch tinder swindler and you're
like
women are stupid am i right
not all women
but for the most part no women no gay
dude is going to fall for that hustle no
straight males gonna [ __ ] you watch you
watch tinder swindler you're like hold
on let me get the straight [ __ ] he gave
you a uh
he flew on a private jet they didn't pay
for and you put out you sold your house
and thought you ate your money back
that's not crazy that's what's crazy is
they like they they're giving them money
they're giving the the the cameras look
you can get scammed for a couple of
minutes but after a while you're like
how much more do you need what's going
on here dude yeah whatever four million
dollars and he was just gambling so he
only did a year so that's like the
tenders when they're they they were like
oh this is all on the girls yeah but do
you know what happens you know how the
government goes listen
the businesses and the girls you're
morons but we'll put them away for
longer because that's yeah that's what
i'm saying this is how they get you how
long do you go but it gets you
now i got a hundred grand out of you
okay i was crying desperate okay i got a
hundred grand now what they say is look
to get the hundred grand back i need
another 10 grand i have to otherwise i'm
not going to get it back i need that
that's [ __ ] and then you go well i i
got to get my hundred grand back so i
got to get 10 grand back i got i need 10
i got it i got to get my money back then
you give them another 10 grand no they
go this is what i need from you listen
tomorrow
that's what but
there's the same thing here
well i you know what i shouldn't say
women are stupid because guys are pretty
stupid too because in that what was that
uh amy you know what i'm talking about
the the young uh with social media
social life what's her name
oh yeah
anna and anna yeah have you seen that
yeah yeah yeah is that a true story yes
kept passing bad chats dude hold on hold
on
dude she hustled a guy who's high up
like dude she was they this bank this
high-end banker and lawyer were about to
clear her for a 40 million dollar loan
with no background in business or
whatsoever she said she came from a rich
german family there's no background on
it she hustled all the elite new york
people they're the worst people on the
planet look at her they're all
sociopaths they are the worst people
they all have this i hate i hate
consciousness like this abcom people are
worse i think they're worse than
murderers
anybody they're the worst i really think
i think i'm not murdered i like the
point and i like to exaggerate myself i
at least murderers kill you
wait so how much how long did she do in
jail the prisons i think she's still in
prison
she did four years and then they went to
extradite her to germany or russia no
the vegan girl uh the vegan girl did
three or six months at uh
rutgers island not bad right rikers but
um anna did four years and then she got
out but then she had to go to ice and
she didn't have the proper papers so
she's still on the ice oh yeah yeah but
they're doing another doctor she did an
interview recently on call her daddy
yeah she'll call her daddy and then
she's also be on the real housewives of
new jersey really oh wow
wait which one this anna who's a
complete con artist complete car artist
but you gotta appreciate the hustle my
thing about ann it's like oh my god it's
him with like haters who are good at
editing and making videos he's like dude
if you would just channel this energy in
something original you would actually
have a legit business but that's not
with anna it's like girl you're
obviously savvy and can have the gifts
of the gab yeah you just channel it to
actual work and get off on the juice
listen brian no one likes waiting on a
paycheck nobody especially when he got
bills dude dude you're stressed out
thank god there's chimes you can get
your paycheck up to two days early with
a direct deposit two days early that's
right that's up to two more days to save
pay bills and generally just feel good
about your money situation is it about
getting so it's just about getting paid
early or something dude it's also an
award-winning mobile app checking
account debit card optional savings
account we got you man so what are you
waiting for hopefully not your paycheck
get started with chime today applying
for a free account takes less than two
minutes get started at chime dot com
fighter that's chime dot com slash got
two minutes man banking services and
debt card provided by the bank corp
bank or stride bank n a members fdic
early access to the direct deposit funds
depends on the payer it just does get
started at triumph.com
i'm gonna start making those disclaimers
super interesting tell me about kratom
dude because i know you take it every
day i'm on it right now daddy i'm like
denzel washington training day i'm drunk
random but now you just want the pure
leaf don't you dude you got to get
kratom it's a super leaf that comes from
deep within the rainforests of southeast
asia farmers have been using kratom
leaves for hundreds of years
reduce pain all right we got you man
gain energy stay focused kratom is
caffeine free there's no chemicals it's
all natural better mood equals better
gains all right superspeciosa is only
one ingredient we're talking about pure
kratom leaf daddy highest quality all
right the highest quality you have 100
satisfaction guaranteed or your money
back and it's certified by third-party
labs i believe right that's right dude
we got you covered if you're gonna try
kratom this is the time to do it
and right now if you want to give kratom
a try go to super specio all right get
super leaf.com is the website it's
getsuperleaf.com
fighter use the promo code fighter to
get 20 off that's get super leaf dot com
slash fighter promo code fighter for 20
off
gets get super leaf dot com slash
fighter promo code fighter for 20 off
juice yeah it's the yeah it's like the
i told you my favorite thing is my
buddy's brother's both his brothers
doormen in new york city
and they make they're in the union so
dorman in new york city all your medical
you make 35 an hour you're you're set
yeah and they were always broke always
broke always broke and i was with him
and he goes [ __ ] i gotta send my
brother money he's [ __ ] always broke
i go oh they're dormant he goes yeah but
they gamble and i said to him i go well
why don't they stop gambling and he said
they can't i said why it goes because
then they would just be dormant
they need some excitement they need yeah
juice they need the juice building a
business or coming with creative
materials
some people get a lot of people get
around they want to take short cuts yeah
the fun is i don't have to do anything
and i still and i make money by being a
sc and then once they do it and they
keep doing it they just get like i also
think they don't i don't think they're
there are sociopaths i think people like
this
don't care who they destroy they destroy
old people they'll they'll think oh
anybody yeah they're the worst people on
the planet the world the guy that guy
was like we could give this baby he had
a baby with this his first baby yeah and
she got pregnant they had the baby and
he said um he goes you know we can give
the baby salt and nobody can tell if it
dies
goes holy [ __ ] okay don't kill though
they're i wonder if there's a common
trait in the people that are getting
scammed like if they all have like a
common trait about them to where they're
just they don't invest in people like
brian gets scammed right now
yeah you know what it is i i always
like you won't i think i'm pretty good
at scumbags like i can see i can be like
mmm you're a piece of [ __ ] but but but
um
i i see the best in people yeah i think
these people do too
there's nothing wrong with seeing the
best of people but i don't think you i
don't think someone's gonna scam if
somebody tells me let me tell you
something right now if somebody goes out
with a navy seal
and or they they go you got follow-up
questions i got follow-up questions and
i'm looking at you yeah and i'm gonna
the one thing i'm really good at maybe
better than anybody is like you can walk
across the street in front of my car
yeah and i know your whole [ __ ] life
i can see how you dress how you walk
yeah i study people real well so that's
the only thing i have going for me where
i can see like if you say something
if you say something i can look at you
and i can usually tell um i don't think
so wait so why do you say that has he
been scammed before no he just means i
see the best in people oh my god
i've had some idiots in my life yeah and
you think that's like the common trait
in those people that are the ones that
get scammed 100
but also that guy
who was uh
you know take on bad vegan
you know
he he was just so full of [ __ ] like even
her dad he he went met her met him for
dinner and he goes what do you do those
black black water ops can't really talk
about it black guy did you tell you tell
my dad that he's like wait what no [ __ ]
when you know give me some d like what's
your background yeah what missions have
you been on what are you talking about
and then what he did is he pretended
that she was talking to another guy who
was like working also for the military
just almost almost kind of catfishing
yeah
and she thought it was a different guy
it was him the whole time
and then he also made her give her all
her passwords and emails and stuff so he
would email people pretend to be her
like don't call don't call me right now
i'm dealing with a lot because they
would check in on him but like okay what
the [ __ ] this so is this pretty much
karma for this for her being a piece of
[ __ ]
cause you said she's a bad she's a bad
person yeah so let me give you uh so
here's a good example you'd like this so
sam sheridan our boy uh patty's husband
so he was writing a book and i went to
work out with this guy who he was going
to put in his book and the guy said
that he was he has phd in phys physical
therapy or physical
whatever it was
and then he also was a professional
fighter
so sam says i was there and sam goes
who was your first fight who was your
first professional fight
and the guy goes ah my first
professional fight you would know right
away guys let me think
uh
oh god and uh sam we both were like oh
he's a liar yeah completely real you're
never gonna forget your first fight what
was your happy place wrestling and he
goes pretty much everything and i go oh
yeah
and then he went like that he went like
that and went like that to samuel yeah
like that and went boom and i go this
guy's a [ __ ] liar and then we said
where
now i got to start digging and i go
where'd you get your phd and what'd you
get your phd in
because well i got my i i got started
out in
russia with i'm like
where'd you get your ph hey answer the
[ __ ] question it's pretty bad i don't
want a geography left yeah yeah
yeah some con on it yeah as soon as you
just hit them with some follow-up
questions well but it's not that hard to
figure out especially with the answer
somebody these days yeah well it's like
you said like well we'll meet people
said i was i was a pro fighter and or i
was a pro boxer and brennan goes where
here
where
i mean
all of a sudden it's wikipedia it's so
funny that people just want to say that
brian used to have this friend he goes
yeah i fought vanderley and check congo
but it was on a beach
what excuse me
oh no i'll look it up what organization
was it oh no
it was like this outdoor
okay cool oh yeah i'm out check please
check please so you get people still
that try to like impress you in a way
like oh yeah man i i used to
not really anymore not really anymore
because the internet's like excuse me
yeah you remember your friend was like
yeah asu i'm like oh my my head coach my
wrestling coach in orange county was on
the team how old are you oh he's that
age last thing is no i heard that guy
he goes wait he wasn't on the team no i
guess you should just come to practice
he goes
we would never let in just a random guy
the practice that's not how well that's
what he say goes then cw that they'd be
cheating didn't see double a won't let
us do that
see there are little things yeah i did
it too you guys i listen i said i ran a
4-3 see it but i but i don't think
that's your fault i think it's your
coach's fault he might and he's just bad
with the clock i know yeah very
different yeah okay he didn't mean to he
legit thought
but also at the same time i didn't know
yeah what are the four things combined
been the fastest ever is it or is i'm
just there's a recent one uh i mean some
guys did but a 300 pound guy you know
i mean then you had another dude
i mean
not those yeah my question is is that
is that almost like gaming the system in
terms of like working with track coaches
and being very specific about it i think
people are getting more athletic bigger
yeah yeah they're probably
you know come from a football back
athletic background more you know their
uncle or dad was in the nfl yeah it's
just genetics to generate because
there's a special there's there's
technique to run in that form oh yeah
yeah
yeah but it's nice forever yeah yeah and
then you mix that with talent it's nice
nightmare
yeah it's a whole different thing i'm
almost finished with palm and pam and
tommy too yeah do you like it so far
yeah it's great have you seen that on
youtube good work oh dude it's so good
really our boy adam raising it he plays
jay leno yeah he's really does a good
job yeah he is yeah adam's a good eye
yeah he's really getting it yeah oh i
saw a horror movie uh x that i think
you'd really like on netflix uh no it's
in theaters so i guess you gotta wait
but it's a good slasher film
yeah it's about a bunch of people trying
to make a porno in the 70s and they get
killed
okay kid cudi's in it you see a shadow
of his dick
it's hilarious i think it's a prosthetic
but still
yeah pam and tom i'm almost done with
it's [ __ ] well done
it makes you feel like you're in the 90s
because now there's a that's a that
little girl's a great actor yeah jen
ortega yeah she was in uh yes she was
yeah i worked with her she was in
sicario i [ __ ] worked with her she's
also in uh richie rich on nickelodeon
but uh yeah she's great
but uh pam and tommy what's interesting
about that is so that got so the story
is and seth rogen plays a guy there's
these guys working on tommy lee's house
doing construction
tommy didn't like what they're doing
it's like get the [ __ ] at her but owed
him like you know 90 grand he's like
[ __ ] you i'm not paying you so you
[ __ ] him over so the guy who tommy did
yeah so the guy that play this all true
story the guy that
actually plays seth rogen
broke in the house later stole his uh
safe and just because he knew there was
cash and watches and jewelry in there
and the sex tape he didn't mean to steal
the sex tape but it was in there yeah
he's like yeah let's see what this is
and puts it in he's like oh it's a sex
tape then he sells it but this is in the
90s and the internet just got started so
they put it out there so it's the first
like internet 95 96 viral video or
whatever but remember at the time
there's no like laws or
like no one thought about doing this
like there's no way to prevent it from
happening couldn't do anything so they
sued but still there's not much you can
do now the laws around are insane oh
yeah if i send cat a dick pic she blasts
on her social media you're [ __ ] captain
yes revenge horn big trump
did he make a fortune no no he made some
money but nowhere near well the guys who
then reached tommy lee went to the
hell's angels
and they were trying to go after him
yeah timely because he you know he's in
with the hell's angels went to them was
like hey this guy did this they showed
up at his house and his place of work
it was a nightmare for him
i don't know what he thought was going
to happen yeah the [ __ ] you think was
gonna happen yeah he stole his [ __ ]
that's bad
wow
why did he [ __ ] them over when he was
doing work probably guys okay guys he
just thought they were doing bad work
and he was tommy's difficult to work
with he's like i want this and like well
he said this he's like well i want this
and they were doing something and time
was just having bad days like man i'mma
hire somebody else get the [ __ ] out of
here he's like we always like 90 grand
for this other work he's like no he
didn't finish it i'm not paying you
and then he then came back to get his
tools tommy pulled a shotgun on him
i was like get the [ __ ] out of my house
he was like all right dude and then he
broke in and stole his safe
i respect that
[ __ ] bad i mean ninety released it
releasing the sex tape pretty [ __ ]
cornball move to do yeah i agree with
that that's [ __ ] up i knew a girl from
cheer this is years ago
she cheered in uh college and um i think
it was like a revenge thing her
boyfriend they broke up i think was a
bad breakup yeah and he had released
pics online she lost everything this is
before like they
made this literally lost
everything i know a guy who sent and it
was just pics that was obviously between
them and their relationship but it got
released and she literally lost that
revenge porn stuff it's easy to track
and now there's yeah there's like ways
to go about finding who
would release my friends
my friend's sister was dating a guy and
then they had a really bad breakup and
he sent a picture of her sucking his
dick a big close-up of her with the big
stuck in her mouth yeah to her dad
oh
yeah and then that's a shitty thing to
do that's very terrible yeah it's tough
to go after them no because i know
because you just sent it
wow there you go that's terrible yeah
i mean pretty easy to figure out who
sent it later and apparently nowadays
your friend said he goes
she had
the picture was her like like that like
like sticking to her like
she she was kind of smiling she was
great
like that was just like jesus he was
like dude
and i don't even know who told me that
story do you think you made it up no i
know i didn't make it up but you heard
from a friend of a friend who knows
where i heard it yeah but you heard it
yeah i said a friend
i said all that
don't remember any of them say friend
all the time yeah you have a lot of
friends yeah yeah don't know i don't
know about that story i just told but i
know what happened yeah you know what
happened somewhere guaranteed probably
it probably didn't happen he has a lot
of friends and there's not much because
you can't really go after for revenge
porn because they didn't post it to the
well that's the way you get somebody
back you send it to the family it's like
you know that a family got to see
they're they're they're cat they were
catfishing people for a while where they
a girl would uh some hot girl would
flirt with some guy
and then
he'd be like yeah yeah yeah and send him
pictures you know kind of fantasy thing
and then she'd go got you
and then she'd just take screenshots and
say now here's your son and your
daughter's profile on instagram here's
your wife's profile i need 200 grand or
they're gonna get
this thread i think you can go after
them for that too well that's called
extortion
yes here's the problem if they're in
another country
different rules different world and that
happens in america you go after but yeah
if they're in like rush or something
yeah it's not a good situation yeah yeah
that should happen all the time what do
you got jen is it not is it hot in here
had a sweatshirt dude have we have we
emailed dean uh kyle said he emailed him
he's waiting on the response or they
said that they're going to send someone
over yeah
yeah not sure when though it's 100
degrees today man
yeah not great hopefully for five years
jeans light color are those happening
with the pockets on the side yeah are
those trendy oh yeah i like that are
those they always come back those those
were around the 80s too
some revived man light down those exact
things
how many degrees yeah no too hot yeah
yeah
oh you were uh influenced by dexter
today but why do you say that he wears
the green top like that he does yeah
it murders people in so true classic
lick sends me stuff off and and uh i
just want green but it's always this
green i want the you want like a dark
yeah dark green yeah the green there
like pops more out there and i want the
blue and i want the the some just keep
saying the green i want summer color
tell them it dude i know a little yellow
a little tangerine yeah yeah
yeah a little pink yeah with my new
straight teeth
these are coming off dude
how long what you got two months left i
got about a month now i got
yeah i got i got i got
80 days and we can't wait
yeah maybe two and a half months we
cannot wait
22 hours a day
hey are you going to do this
what's up with that
can you can you slide me a pair or what
i don't know do you know what guy i'll
ask him you know what guy my sizes
i like those those are vans yep some
fannies
are they comfy cups the other kind i
like that i like i actually like that
color you don't need them anymore no i
don't need them anymore yeah my foot's
hundred percent now i'm glad that's good
can you
show the
shoes to the camera i'm sure to see it
but danny ricardo's thank you
cool
look winter is supposed to be
hibernation time okay i'll tell you and
but a lot of people stay in more than
usual but that doesn't mean
that you're not busy or that you don't
want to spend all your time in the
kitchen okay but here's the thing
sometimes you don't have to meal plan or
prep
and you can still you don't want to do
you want to eat well and that's where
factor comes to play they make it easy
for me to eat clean 24 7 with fresh
never frozen prepared meals that are so
delicious you wouldn't believe they're
actually good for their chef crafted
meals and they and they send them to
your doorstep eliminates the hassle of
grocery shopping meal prep no cleanup no
cleanup dishes not up in here no it's
ready in just two minutes even it's
that's fashion or in waiting well
they've got registered dietitians and
expert chefs that work hand-in-hand to
create meals with nutritious ingredients
dude i got 29 meal options
every week you never get bored all right
they offer vegan keto meals low calorie
cold cold-pressed juices smoothies
plant-based bars extra protein veggie
sides they keep you fueled all day long
all right go to
go.that's go.factor75.com
120 that code so easy to use
go to
go.factor75.com
fighter120 use the code fighter120 get
120 bucks off that's code fighter120 at
go
go.factor75.com
fighter 120 for 120 off listen you want
total human optimization you gotta on it
we set it a thousand dollars oh my god
they've been ours they're drilled in
your
they've been our sponsor since the
beginning of this [ __ ] podcast our
boys
first sponsor they're still a sponsor
they got alpha brain they got new mood
they got digestive stuff they got
essential nutrients they got daily
support they've got the best
krill oil is the best fish oil you know
i'm sick of telling them all the stuff
they have dude if you're not using on it
you ain't sure scientific research go to
onit.com you get 10 off all supplements
nutrition protein you got uh dark roast
coffee got warrior bars elk bars we got
fitness gear for your thick ass yeah
kettlebells we got streaming fitness
programs you do from your frickin phone
you got no excuses battle ropes sandbags
steel club maces quad maces we got it
all there's no reason to be stupid thick
anymore go to
audit.com10 off listen man i want you
guys to come see me in
tampa
on april 15 16 improv then i got poor
charlotte but you're not going to sound
racist
i will be wearing my braces on stage you
won't see it go buy tickets to them
don't do it i was making them out of
wise guys comedy club april 28th 30th
new brunswick club uh stress factory may
5th and through the 7th that's what i'm
excited about brennan where are you
going to be before we get into
some messages the tough mudder this
saturday thick mudder is at 10 30 a.m
can still sign up if you want we have
over 470 thickies running with me and
mark harley
it's 10 30 a.m start time 15 k and 5k
we'll see if my hammies hold up and then
next thursday friday saturday i'm at
stand up live in phoenix arizona then
austin texas april 22nd to 23rd that
will be for the moon tower comedy
festival at the new cap cities
i'm cracking the the seal the cherry the
new cap cities in southern texas great
and then april 28th my special drops
only on think boy youtube i can't wait
all right first one all right
this is a little update on the elon musk
poll on twitter asking if he thinks
twitter is a good place for free speech
he actually ended up buying
9.2 percent of the twitter stocks which
makes him the largest single inves uh
stockholder
in twitter so i don't know what that
necessarily means for decision making
but he owns a very large chunk of
twitter now unless he's on the board
right i don't know
i believe he is
9.2
yeah which is the largest amount a
single individual owns
okay it says announced elon is becoming
a board member interesting which should
be awesome
yeah right i think so i'm a fan yeah me
too more free speech boss moved by him
that could happen [ __ ] could have
been cheap
he's got the money yeah
like a spider snickers bar
disturbing one a rapper recently died
from got from gun violence and his
family decided that they wanted to hold
a celebration for him by
throwing a party at a nightclub in dc
what they failed to tell the nightclub
is that they were going to take his
corpse and have it in the club while
everyone was partying so there's a video
of his corpse we're assuming that it's
been embalmed i believe that's the term
and they just have him posted up at the
club while everyone's partying and
people didn't know until they were
people
yeah and the venue was like yeah the
venue did not know let me see
how did you sneak that in there
so this is the rapper's corpse
this [ __ ] is dope
that [ __ ] dope
dude
hey if that's what he wanted i don't
think he had a choice
like that kid's all what in the [ __ ]
people are like what the [ __ ]
it is very strange
people who were coming to the
celebration knew that was gonna happen
until they showed up and was like wait
that looks a little he looks terrifying
yeah
yeah he's dead right there yeah yeah he
did that is insane oh god
all right well
did they take the body off stage right
everybody thanks for coming just drag
the button yes what do you get what do
you do oh gosh
i think i told you that story about
jimmy's uh buddy these the the guys
his daughter's fighting with the
boyfriend
father comes outside the boyfriend says
not to get involved father's
longshoreman beats the [ __ ] out of the
boyfriend kills the boyfriend oh well
boyfriend starts fighting kills him
calls his buddy bozo bozo was a knuckle
breaker on the docks he had the longest
tongue in the world jimmy said that his
tongue would come past his [ __ ] chin
like that like he'd put his stick his
thumb around and you'd go oh jesus like
what the [ __ ] you know shitty talent
yeah giant guy shitty talent unless his
name is bozo unless you're a gay man
name is bozo he's a giant man who was a
knuckle breaker so they time to a gurney
time to a dolly a dolly
and this is this is how brilliant they
are they're like well it's two in the
morning three in the morning
they roll them they roll him to the gas
station
and they just drop them there like and
they just leave there i can see you
later cool well the next morning
the cops
they go hi
did you roll a body
they're like no and they go well our
dogs took you right here oh and the
reason our dogs took you right here is
because like in the weekend and burning
his [ __ ] hand had slipped out
and it dragged along the [ __ ] ground
and dogs i don't know if you know this
have very good noses yeah and the dog
was just like
right
yeah and they went away for a while
would you hear that story my buddy jimmy
burke okay there we go that's a real
story
bozo did life probably both didn't do
life
yeah the dad probably went away for a
little bit he went away for 11 years or
nine years dad went away from nine
involuntary manslaughter and then uh his
you know in his bozo went away for like
not
like 18 months for helping and embedding
this guy worked at docks
yeah i thought you said he was going to
like dump it in the water or something
yeah no that'd be more sense
that would make sense yeah
and not a gas station yeah you ever hear
like sammy the gravana talking about
talking about working with the westies
and the westies where the irish gang on
the upper west and they would do [ __ ]
for the gambino family like they would
do like they would you know kill people
and stuff like that yeah the problem was
they would be so drunk and high and so
they'd be like you know they they're
like listen rough them up a little bit
to send a message what do they do they
shoot him in the ass six times got his
head off put his head in the tv yeah
they're like
his head's in the tv we said smack him
around wild boys you shot him in the ass
and put his head in the you cut his head
off and put it in the what the [ __ ] are
you doing oh yeah
hilarious
all right
next one
t.i was at a comedy show where i guess
he was going to perform and the host had
made a joke about the sexual assault
allegations with t.i and his wife yes
there is video of t.i going off on the
host let me see it yeah
this winter yeah
you coming with that turtleneck
[ __ ] evidence because there was no
[ __ ] crap
from her
i think she has a microscope
[Music]
and if you keep on playing with me [ __ ]
i'm gonna [ __ ] continue to confront
you publicly verbally
is
oh there you go bring it in bring it in
bring it in
he's cool
now she's mad
they start playing one of his hits he
starts they cut his mic off
yeah that's where it turns into a stuff
if you're at a show you're like this did
you see uh he ran the light 20 minutes
at the store [ __ ] and i just keep
putting them up yeah the guy
someone came and tapped him like hey
you're gonna get it get up yeah you
gotta get off this ain't going well yeah
cause because they i guess they were
lighting them a lot
and uh he i don't i just think he didn't
no i think he knows you think you know
100 i mean huh yeah it's fair but i
can't believe that i guess yeah but he
had to go it's in the bell it was in the
belly room and he had to go behind like
basically the black curtain yeah to like
because he didn't want to like go up on
stage and tap him so he tried to do it
kindly you see he's just like yeah his
hand tells him he goes and he goes did
you
like 20 minutes that's insane yeah
that's not the best way to get into
stand-up yeah but just pissing off all
the comics running the light is his
music thing he's not doing as much of it
anymore uh i don't know if he's dropped
anything but i mean
and
and within recent i'm not i'm not too
sure i listen to a lot of his older
stuff but i don't know
if he's dropped anything as far as
recent i don't think so
uh we got to [ __ ] fight companion
this saturday all right that's right
daddy do you have uh who's
who's the [ __ ] uh lana we got i i'm
just excited about that gilbert burns
chimaya thing
um i i just want to see you that's i
just want to see you just drop music in
a hot [ __ ] no i don't think yeah yeah
it's been a while
wow oh two weeks ago
mm-hmm oh okay so four million oh no no
he might have i think oh so it looks
like he's got an album that just dropped
yeah two weeks ago most recently nine
months ago okay he's still doing music
yeah he's still ten months ago nine
months ago yeah
he got some bangers
um
rubber band man yeah rubber band man
yeah whatever you like yeah what you
know about that let's go about that what
else you got jen
all right
here we go the world's biggest dark net
marketplace was recently taken down and
authorities were able to seize 25
million in bitcoin it was the german uh
i guess it's their equivalent of like
the fbi mm-hmm and uh the u.s federal
law enforcement actually took place in
taking this now is it like the silk road
yeah very similar
seventeen million murder for hire [ __ ]
whoa
nineteen thousand registered sellers
and it was estimated that the dark net
this particular website saw point three
four billion dollars to say what they're
selling keep going drugs and uh forged
documents i'm sure it's anything you
could get on the dark web yeah they sell
but the dark web still popping in
america yeah yeah i believe so oh yeah
yeah
it's where they don't take that down yes
they can it's really hard yeah i don't
think again at least i know
but i think that there are plenty of
people on the dark web monitoring it but
you can buy drugs you can buy all kinds
of stuff it's it's the the kiddie porn
stuff that they need to crack down on
disgusting that's what they have to
crack down
what then happens with the bitcoin
that's seized usually and stuff like
that i don't really know
i know now with blockchain it's easier
to track where the bitcoin is right so
um they can find your address i don't i
might just
where's my millions of dollars for towed
nfts okay i'm glad you asked that
remember that scam
oh i remember when i got scammed
hey bad vegan
i don't know what you guys talking about
what was that
remember your hustle to get all our
friends involved no i didn't i went no
no i don't think so no i did very
purposely i said i was very aware of
that i go this looks like i can get a
lot of people involved and use you
bought quite a few i i bought it i
bought it i lost money nobody else did i
lost [ __ ] so you guys i bought you
some i didn't get scammed uh you took a
chance yeah i took a chance because i i
thought i wanted his friends his friends
told him one thing my friend got kind of
taken too he he put a lot of money into
it and what happens is they released too
many of them it would have been great if
they were the values yeah yeah yeah
so that was the problem but i i was very
purposeful about i didn't want to get
because what a lot of [ __ ] are
doing is they they get a group of people
pump and dump that's that's something
that i think is [ __ ] immoral
unethical and shitty
wait so what they do is they go oh hey
guys lex if so i could have gotten all
the comics together start talking about
frogs or toads okay
now now
everybody now all the fans buy toads who
listen to podcasts now all the fans buy
toads and now the price goes up and then
we all sell our toads and that's called
being an [ __ ] yeah dishonest and
being essentially criminal in my opinion
they see dancing soldier boy got got
nancy
so now it's easy it's easy to get caught
up in it so now what they're what the
government's trying to do is get banks
to create these enclosed ecosystems so
they issue it that a bank will issue or
a
credited
lender will issue a coin
now you buy that coin
the bank that get that that sells you
the coin takes that money and they put
it into a non-profit
so a non-profit gets money they get a
low interest loan
now with that low interest loan
the money that they pay back
buys more coins so the coin goes up in
value the government's trying to get
that going because that becomes an
enclosed ecosystem when they do that
that that's a different story because
the money is being used for a [ __ ]
non-profit and used for charity
okay but but right now these nfts and
all this [ __ ] that's my spidey says
yes
we both go that way we start laughing i
go i can't believe i'm talking about
toads i go i'm going to buy you a buddy
i'm going to buy you a bunch
let's see what happens we tried it i
don't know if this is one of the
articles but there was something about
i think i saw this morning about the
head of blm
and bought like a six million dollar
house she's not the head of it anymore
for that reason yeah she took all the
profits and bought multiple properties
all over it and she bought it in 2020 so
yeah like the highest one height of it
she's out that whole thing's
they ate their own so what happens to
her off that nothing people i mean just
the whole movement's [ __ ] you realize
it's just a hustle
she's basically brian trying to tell me
tony
i think she was selling like black i
think i think if you sold like an nft of
the first so
uh that would be worse
yeah
oh my god
she purchased four high-end homes for
3.2 million dollars each
six million dollars in cash yeah uh
that's that's like 12. that's a little
illegal that's very good nothing happens
to her
i remember this article from before i
remember from when i think the
government's like yeah we don't touch
this one
she's a
she's i believe a vowed
trained marxist she talks about being a
marxist yeah she wants out of the
household
yeah
yeah there are a lot of things that
she's uh
she's probably not
there you go alicia garza and other blm
members purchased the home in october it
wasn't just her yeah
she yeah it was like a dog let's
capitalize on this [ __ ] people get
like yeah wouldn't have more power and
more money yeah well yeah exactly
we're also like these people are crooks
you know first of all they're not trying
to make a change in the black movement
these people saw an opportunity to make
money and capitalize on it take
advantage of this entire movement their
completeness that's very possible to you
yeah what else you get
i don't watch basketball but i'm sure
you guys do right and i'm sure you i do
so the lakers were eliminated before
they could even go into playoff
contention right yeah it's a big deal
which is pretty crazy yeah yeah but it
was funny because people are making fun
of the lakers because they had like the
oldest lineup in the league
and they posted a picture like before
the season of their lineup people were
like yo the golden girls of the nba and
lebron's like we'll see who's laughing
when the playoffs come
it's just it's
crazy yeah and then they have the big
russell westbrook contract which [ __ ]
them over like they're in a bit of
trouble man russell westbrook oh hugh's
consciousness he has a huge like
with the lakers yeah yeah but the way
that the nba works like because he got
it he's got a contract so you gotta
you get
really rough here i'm a fan of him too
but rough yeah
yeah uh they played the suns last night
yeah the suns are who eliminated them
yeah yeah suns are good with booker
no one in the west
all right
this is pretty disturbing i don't i can
only go off of what i see in the video
here okay but so there's this uh he
happens to be a black hotel clerk in
fort lauderdale florida
and i guess this white dude who happens
to be a race car driver he tried to come
in before and get a room but apparently
he was really drunk and somehow he
attacked the clerk
or the other the front desk guy and then
the police escorted him back home or to
a friend's house and then he came back
and attacked the dude again the black
dude again so here's a video on it
really good fight
i mean look at this
it's very infuriating watching this one
no this is the second one when he came
back why are they making it a black
white thing because he happens to be
black and have to be white that's it's
not i don't know if it's a black one it
came in it could be just two people that
just well at least the black guy's kind
of weapon is that yeah and he by the way
he was attacked he's also drunk nice the
white dude rushed him
okay all right so he's doing this this
guy's beating the [ __ ] out of him yeah
so eventually he holds him down and this
this guy helps out or tries to help out
when you say race car driver what are we
talking about here i like nascar i don't
look like he's a race car driver says
his race car driver
race car driver is that code for a huge
[ __ ] yeah so the white dude he's
actually saying i can't breathe or you
know let me he goes like no
mess yeah screw you blah blah blah
you're breathing son yeah you're talking
you're breathing well i don't know okay
right brandon
so the the black dude he's like by the
way i should just say his name
it's just he just yeah
i know why are we making it we're shaw i
think we're raymond rashaal he was
saying like you know help you know
bring you know all the cops why are they
saying racial things i don't think so i
think this they accuse him he so in the
report it says that he was saying some
racial slurs yeah but either way he
rushed the the rashawn still yeah he's
in trouble
no well check this out this is where it
gets crazy i i know it just i've seen
this yeah so here's the cops the cops
finally come
hold on wait so you'll see here
in this video they fast forward it the
cops come look what what happens here
they get the black guy yeah pushing the
blind dude we're trying to get off and
look he's not pushing back right now
he's still pushing him oh wow yeah
jesus he's like dude
why are they coming so eventually
video reveals a shocking new angle of a
hotel brawl in florida
previously released certainly no i mean
i don't know
that caught that cop particularly
no i don't mean the cops so he was taken
to jail but he was released and then the
i guess the
the prosecution dropped all charges on
the on rashaw of course and there's an
investigation that's going on but when
you look at this video it's so
infuriating because and they give people
to get right home yeah jesus the first
time like the first the first time he
got a ride home that'd be uh what's it
called bias the same fort lauderdale
that just last month fired its 24 year
old veteran police because six of 15
promotions made were
um people of color
discriminating against white people
i don't know it's just yeah it's
infuriating watching
that well at least the black guy didn't
get beat up
yeah well yeah he held his own shot yeah
yeah yeah oh i thought you were like
yeah walked out like this
but the pushing was like come on dude
that's why a good thing you have video
yeah exactly video that guy would have
been in jail right now
yeah that was terrible
all right so we're tired of will smith
stuff but just a real quick i'm not
saying as far as his resignation from
the academy i don't care all it is
so he can still get a best actor award
for his you know king richard thing uh
he can always get invited to the future
academy award ceremonies he can still be
nominated he can't vote but he just
can't vote which is so lame dude so when
people like take his oscars
you know even [ __ ] uh harvey
weinstein won an oscar then take it from
him you know the guy what's his name
raped a young [ __ ] girl asking and
they didn't take his office yeah they're
not taking his oscar it's so stupid
so he he doesn't but the resignation is
so lame oh what a sacrifice i don't know
what they can't [ __ ] you know they're
gonna do sacrifice they're never gonna
do that they've only taken it once it
was like 1960 and they [ __ ] up because
the the movie that won
actually
was past the date where they could apply
and they realized it after the fact and
took the award because they weren't no
they couldn't
give them the award because they they
weren't in the time frame that's the
only time they've taken away why that i
know that i have no idea but also
um
will smith is suffering now because like
netflix who has a big cat yeah they
pulled all right
[Music]
you know what they're giving them a
timeout
right it's going to last six months
maybe yeah i don't think
i'm so sick i'm amazing it's one billion
i'm amazed they pulled it i'm amazed
that they actually yeah i wouldn't no
that way
yeah chris rock seems fine yeah his
projects his projects are all kind of
all of them put on hold which is i'm
surprised by i thought he suffered no
ramifications
yeah
but you know people are like let's just
give it a second that what they're doing
is they go we'll give it let's give it a
breather that's how they're doing this
this this end the news cycle and i'll
give another week i'm already so sick
yeah yeah yeah i don't get it it was it
made the oscars two billionaires
slapping each other who cares they're in
tuxedos the last thing on this ricky
gervais you guys love ricky javascript i
saw the what he said about it he's like
i would not make fun of the her hair
i'll make fun of her with her new her
boyfriend yeah yeah that's the move yeah
that was actually pretty funny
i guess chris rock went up in new york
the other night just doing a spot and
was like i'm not talking about the world
i think you guys are expecting that i'm
not doing that
he said one which is he'll eventually
get to it but he's not going out he does
which he will it's gonna be funny
this i don't okay it's not big news but
albert pujols
who's a
mlb player right yeah hall of famer he's
that he's terrible now but he's also 60.
oh okay well he's older all right oh he
is he's a hall of famer yeah cardinals
hall of famer he's so old now yeah
they the the cardinals just signed him
so he can retire as a cardinal that's it
okay he's done well i just saw this
headline it just seemed pretty crazy not
crazy but it seemed pretty like
insensitive but then you know okay so it
says pull
his divorce days after his wife just had
brain surgery she had to remove a big
tumor from her brain until that surgery
didn't want to stress her out he said
it's like it's not the best time to do
it but we had issues a long time before
so this is just you know he's got it
people are mad that he's doing it now
yeah yeah no we're talking hey no they
should be proud that he stayed with her
and supported her through her brains you
know i'm with you on that too
get through it make sure you heal yeah
22 years of marriage should be
celebrated he served 22 years
for 22 years a long time the longest
shout out to both of them for making
that [ __ ] work that's a success you do
some traffic 22 years that's a success
you're a superstar baseball player you
do some traveling yeah right dude well
you know there's some uh slump bunnies
out there what if you're in a slump yeah
is when you're like you know you're 0
for 16. and then you they call it a
slump bust because you got to find just
the troll and hook up with it oh dale
you hit the whole station that's the
thing yeah now now now are you
suggesting that
some superstar stud dominican makes 400
baseball players on the road
are not 100 faithful for 22 years of
marriage
i'm asking you a question at least she's
survived 22 years it's a success story
you think he was faithful the whole time
who knows
hey hey
whoa
i said who knows
pro athletes like that are
there's listen there has to be a very
faithful
laugh i think that's because
i feel like maybe sure i wanted to be
sandy
yeah sure no
here's the thing about all i don't know
why i just i believe
no i mean 80 [ __ ] we don't know of
course not but we don't know my thing is
that at 22 years of marriage regardless
big deal that's a big [ __ ] deal that
should be celebrated they should both
odds are they're not going to make it
they deserve a trophy that's not easy to
do period when anybody in hollywood will
smith jada pinkett smith 25 years of
marriage
they are that that well that's amazing
well regardless of what they have to do
to make it that's amazing
and she looks
she couldn't look better she's 50 yes
she's attracted do you look better at 50
it's unbelievable she's hot yeah she's
hot she's very attractive alpicia or not
yeah let's try a different marriage with
the difficulty let's do denzel and his
wife he's he denzel
they've been together
man on fire
man on fire
don't talk about denzel like that that
is a very well-mannered man we never
said i'm very intelligent no y'all
aren't playing i'm not implying
let me see
let me see if i love denzel no don't
choose a i love denzel you guys are
telling him santa's not real that that's
what this that's what you're doing we're
doing chapelle it's solid i know you're
not saying that
yeah i love that
if i saw denzel washington with 17 women
i would keep my mouth look at that
yeah oh i'd bury a body for denzel
washington me too and i don't even know
me too i love that yeah dude she's
smoking yeah she's beautiful yeah yeah
yeah you know what they've been hey
they've been together how long they've
been together if denzel washington's
faithful it doesn't surprise me at all
thank you it doesn't
how long have you been together getting
to the head brian since 83. go to the
head go to the head dude training
use your words wisely what are we saying
what are we done to the head gun to the
head brian you have to bet in life in
hollywood the biggest movie star in the
world big
he's on location in italy for modeling
biggest movie star in the world no his
holly talent models don't like dental
watch they don't like him the thing
about him is he doesn't walk outside and
have
it
because he keeps doing they keep doing
themselves twelves thirteen's fourteen
you know the scale beyond ten that that
well denzel it's r10
denzel this is why i think he's faithful
they keep to themselves you don't see
denzel yeah
agreed you know what i'm saying they
keep to themselves you're right you know
what the thing is what you don't know
denzel
no neither do i
that's the problem
let me let me
tell you something
tell me something tell me something
there's a world out there that none of
us are privy to
there's a world out there now i've had i
have had that door opened a couple of
times and i've been able to look inside
you know what happened you did you
talked about the you're talking about
the boom boom room here's here's what
we've seen in the boom room someone's
opening like check it out and then they
shut the door
yeah let me just yeah i'll wait in line
holy you see what and that's it it's
like that
well well i have a friend world famous i
have a world hold on i have a friend
world famous denzel's internationally
known you got no idea and neither do i
well i was our we have a friend but to
assume that he no we i we have a friend
i'll tell you all fair who it is and
he's like dude i'm getting all this
attention from ladies now like look at
my dams he showed me the damn thing
that's crazy i go now think about this
you're getting these dams and you went
whatever viral on a youtube video or
tick tock where the [ __ ] is you imagine
being like drake or chris brown
you can't unless you've been i go
imagine their dna you can't unless
you've been like you think you're you
feel good right now and whatever you can
call these girls over imagine being lean
they probably just throw their phones
they throw their phones let me let me
give you one you just go scroll through
and go what is it tuesday afternoon okay
here we go click let me do that let me
do you one better too denzel washington
was famous at a time when there was one
there's no no cameras and one guy who
was the biggest movie star in the world
in a way like back then when you were in
a movie the world saw it so whenever you
went anywhere
you were like the king dude you don't
think he was getting his dick sucked on
the set of crimson time i don't know
what was happening no
i don't either dude don't you i dare i
have
washington is a very disciplined man
control over everything he did i don't
know about that
washington what i will say is this
denzel washington
had more attention from women
that we can't even no one can say social
media pre-cameras
but when i say when i say more than i'm
not talking about one woman i'm talking
about
three at a time who are like we all i
mean
it's out of control well like like
michael irvin said he goes i wasn't just
getting double-teamed on the field i
talked to him i talked to my colleagues
i talked to michael irvin about that oh
you used to say like he was on track
he was like i'll put it this way
after the game or before the game i
wasn't even just double teaming on the
field
really we had multiple ones so before
the game after the game so they had they
had a they had a and he was in marriage
so the cowboys the superstar cowboys had
there was the there was the row where
their wives sat
and there was a row where their gals no
excuse no sir they all went so newton
uh michael irvin emmett smith and
troykman went in on the house it was
called the white house it was a huge
mansion yeah where they would all just
run them up yeah they'd
run around that is such a [ __ ]
different lifestyle
i'm so naive
yeah i got another one for you
what a lot of times famous people will
do is if there's a strip club in the
area like a famous one
they they rent that out and they but no
no but
now they rent them out for themselves
and just well or they go how much you're
making for the night we have a house oh
hey ladies you guys want to come back
how much you making for the night oh i
have money
i have a huge crib you can come over to
and they're not done
they have handlers so you don't know
about this yeah you don't have handlers
yeah
let's say i'm lebron do you get the
lebron yeah yeah yeah you gotta go
through old ranks you gotta go through
ranks and he he he runs [ __ ] he runs a
tight ship oh i gotta see your phone you
gotta see your phone and and now and
then also the one who's not a 13 who's a
10
you gonna suck off old rinks
now we're getting creepiest [ __ ] i don't
know i think we were what what don't say
about this is the book of motley crew
yeah motley crue okay so wait their
their handlers are getting women too oh
i think they get the vip people yeah
that whole thing gets weird i read the
motley crue that's a [ __ ] different
world a lot of them used to have
they play play oh i don't have a solo
they would go underneath the stage and
[ __ ] women yeah chappelle and here's the
thing chappelle
like if tommy lee's doing his drum solo
by himself they can be down there like
hey but here's the basis is like oh i'm
not playing right now let me get my dick
sucked for three minutes and here's the
other thing about that there are a lot
of women that get off on that there are
a lot of women that like that and guys
there are a lot of people that love
there's this under this this is such a
different [ __ ] world there's this
undertale
there's a whole underworld that happens
that's all like you don't know about but
there are people that there are girls
that just get off on doing weird [ __ ]
with that you know paul fitch
yeah yeah when being reigns when they
open up the thing it glows gold you're
like oh what is that yeah that's the
boom boom room
yeah i don't know
well it looks cool i've never been in
there it's where things
run amok yeah that is so [ __ ] crazy
oh oh crazy cool crazy corner
if i crazy i would be so [ __ ]
stressed
well no it's not for you yeah that's
fair not and and i don't think we're
ever going to get that either
what do you got for me you'd be stressed
in the beginning
and then what was that being a bit
relieved it's like anything else brendan
isn't it like the first time you're in a
ring you're [ __ ] swinging you're
running away and then after about six
seven months when you learn how to move
and stuff sometimes you can make
yourself a little not even that's a bad
analogy i would say that
i would say that's a terrible analogy
and you went way too detailed okay i
would say it's like skiing first time
down a little scary going downhill
you're like snow you fall through
terrifying
second time a little easier isn't it you
got hot cocoa waiting for you 10th time
10th time 10th 12th
time
we're going black diamonds i'm on the
moguls correct my moguls i mean tits
yeah
so chappelle
you'd be just fine be just fine waters
be a little rough when you start i know
god i know you know you're running the
ship i know a guy i know a guy a very
conservative guy a [ __ ] conservative
and talks exactly like you and in fact
very conservative guy in a lot of ways
and never really i know him well never
stepped out of line and he had a
conversation with a very famous man and
he said yeah i would never do that and
the man said you haven't seen the kind
of woman women
that exist at 5 000 an hour and he said
it wouldn't matter he said you don't
think it would matter he said no i you
know he said okay so there there are
women that you can pay five grand a
night or five grand an hour or whatever
it is and one of them showed up at his
door they just wanted to see what would
happen and um they're
so they're scale one to ten these are
twelve yeah and guess what happened
he wrestled he skied he skied he was
skiing he went right down i got straight
for this for now about this so my boy
lex mcmahon his dad who passed away ed
mcmahon
ed mcmahon was part of the rat pack it's
my favorite story from lex mcmahon
so he was with the rat pack and they
were all in vegas you know with the most
famous men in the world at the i mean
couldn't get any bigger no so he was
really close with frank sinatra frank
sinatra ran the show he was the captain
of the team they all sat down for lunch
or for dinner it was there it was late
after show and ed mcmahon's there and
he's a young man and franco's would
wouldn't he told you something sinatra
yeah when he told you something you do
it he's you know he ties to mafia he's
the biggest guy yeah and he goes ed you
need to go to bed and that just got like
a porterhouse steak he was the [ __ ] i'm
growing mangoes i don't give a [ __ ] go
to bed and that's like no i'm not going
to bed he's like i'm not going to tell
you again dude go to your [ __ ] room
go to bed that's like [ __ ] but
it's right sinatra's like [ __ ] this
throws the stake it's like [ __ ]
what rushes up to his room walks in
there's two
tens waiting for from frank sinatra
how dope is that thanks frank
thanks frank you're the best friend of
all time yeah i mean best friend of all
you need to go to bed now huh yeah now
for me i i would go to bed i'd go
i'd pick i go i go okay whatever's going
on sometimes
i don't give a [ __ ]
if you tell me to go to bed i'm going
i'm going to be up there okay i'll go to
bed all right there yeah wow let's get
you
that's it dude that was wild
we put we put chappelle on game now my
my guess is this was probably the
epstein island kind of [ __ ] with all
these famous men
like yeah because there are black male
you like uh they'd like no she's legal
and then hey bubba we supported that and
she's 16. yeah or seven couldn't work
with that and now if you don't give us
what we want yeah
release this yes so you're gonna do what
we say now now they're part of it that's
what i believe what's happening that's
what i think yeah a little bit different
uh
uh if if you do want to get in the boom
boom room not as cool
by boom boom room i mean all cox i will
be at stand up live april 14th through
the 16th that's next thursday friday
saturday with a thick boys squad we'll
be at jt's wings on saturday come get
some wings and talk to your boys then
austin texas moon tower comedy festivals
april 22nd to 23rd
uh april 28th my special drops on
youtube thick boy channel can't wait for
you guys to see it then just announce we
just [ __ ] put it up today charlotte
north carolina is may 5th through the
7th then philly is may 19th through 21st
but
stand up live in phoenix you're up next
thursday through saturday tickets at
thickboy.com everybody so we have a
fight company this saturday 7 p.m
pacific live on think boy youtube we got
brian callan matt matrion josh thompson
and myself for ufc
come watch it with your boys tune in
that's it yeehaw tampa florida tampa
improv april 15th and 16th not this
weekend but next weekend come get some
friday saturday i got two shows friday
two shows saturday tampa improv port
charlotte florida
yeah vasani comedy theater april 21
22-23 come get some las vegas nevada
wise guys comedy club april 28th 29th
and 30th and then i got the stress
factory in new jersey new brunswick new
jersey stress factory may 5th 6th and
7th can't wait one of my favorite clubs
haven't done it in years come get some
salt lake city i'll see you this weekend
uh friday and saturday at uh wiseguys
comedy club then may 6th and 7th i'll be
in san diego at a new comedy club and
out there called mic drop comedy club
and then i'm doing a one-nighter in the
hometown may 12th at stand up live
all right kids love you we're out